ladies and gentlemen
london is
but don't worry we've got our best man
on the case
because if anyone can fix this mess it's
this smooth
super spy oh
well looks like we're recruiting
it's a state of emergency move in and
lock down the city
in the chaos private armies have taken
the streets
albion securities contract has been
extended indefinitely
a crooked spy agency lurks in the
shadows
it's basic tradecraft want to sell a lie
weave it into the truth
and organized crime has grabbed the old
city by the
the kellys have got a human organ black
market now but i've got to keep tracks
on my merchandise tonight
the government's literally letting
albion shoot us in the street
you need to build a resistance recruit
anyone in the whole city
and i really mean anyone genius hackers
hard crafters idiots
everyday people with something to fight
for and something unique to offer
the right person for the job
or the ones you least expect
the city needs a resistance and it
starts with you
what do you say yeah i'm in
welcome to the resistance
face is on gun's out it's about to get
real
find them recruit them
welcome to the resistance